welcome to this video huh playing Hagen
yeah this guy all the time wouldn't be
3f okay and this is one of the people I
have the absolute best score against 17
out of 21 this kind of ridiculous okay
he's playing this is interesting pushing
on the queenside yeah I have to get some
play on the kingside to compensate for
that let's see when to take on c3 first
yeah maybe okay now how do I get some
play going Knight f6 to e4 first mm or
something with e5 can also try for
something with e5 taking all their three
and then e five this kind of thing
b6 root a one now okay okay so he allows
the strayed okay let's let's push
getting some kind of counter play
hmm just wanted to switch off this the
signal took me a moment it was just my
phone okay so he decided to close the
queenside interesting yeah the main idea
of that is to somehow gets to the b7
pawn of course but not clear if and how
is going to manage that okay so five
maybe why not I can't play with a FOID
f4 I mean this kind of this kind of
thing crew k8s always Bishop takes H to
check
okay so i would like to play night of
six but unfortunately math warnings
it's not so easy maybe here 45 I can go
get it so it's kind of annoying this is
move ok Knight a5 or what ok maybe you
just wants to go 95
not sure how dangerous that is so maybe
here
yeah that looks nice but you see really
getting somewhere with it don't know
I'm not saying why this goes or anything
of course not but I'm not sure how
dangerous this is if I would manage
somehow to unpin this stuff I would be
in really nice shape that's a very
interesting thing yeah ticks but isn't
this good wait wait wait wait wait wait
i'm going to take this and King f70 this
is threatening Butchie a droopy for
stuff now this must be good for for me
right Luke g Heydrich g4 thats it's
really hard to believe for white is that
ok I can also go nigh g44 night h to
check which in my take that that he
might take but i can go here right
tricky business
maybe I can finally unpin unpinned this
here with bishop h2 as weird as it looks
but
very very true very tricky that wasn't
the only way to play i also had more
complicated things i work a seven-year
scott i didn't think about that one ah
that's not good i have to play such a
passive move that's not good
not good at all time warning check yep
going from going for some counter play
him on the e-file
Queen f5 I don't know what's better
really queen is succession of two are
the same I have to move 40 seconds
alright Ricky rupee 17 g 8 and then i
have this counter attack this is 1.3 in
the u 1 square check this check though
yeah I kind of swindled him maybe maybe
it was a swindle maybe I was okay i
really don't know check probably it was
a swindle check
check
white for fence for my gosh yeah I don't
know that was that was very very
difficult this position let's say around
here that that's extremely difficult to
to assess I mean it looks looks
problematic but can you do something I
don't know computer says equal but hard
to say if the engine is revived reliable
here because there might be some
elaborate plan for white for I don't
know some are regrouping and then
sacrificing to break through on the
queenside I am not really buying it
because i have this half counter play on
the con the kingside the h4 was kind of
shocking yeah as you computer agrees
that black black is better now King age
seven supposed to be better don't really
know why because of F form mmm King f1f
for strong okay and it's almost winning
my very difficult very difficult to to
play and it was such was really really
tricky here f3 yeah f for this is the
computers just I thought about this move
briefly but then I thought it's just too
wacky the idea is that this is this is
probably quite good idea with the
japones the bonds rolling I saw that one
actually but it did look too too weird
to me player for I didn't really know
what I'm threatening here f takes e4 d
takes us the computer line and then
we'll create like it's good okay
yeah it just is just a complete complete
mess and here I overlooked your guy
seven simply yeah this means that Bishop
h2s is a bad museum I should play
something like that getting the King out
of the seventh and computer says 000 am
probably find some kind of Perpetual and
here here I'm worse when I have to place
a dis passively ok but Bishop you won
king d want a stronger and this is good
all of a sudden again for black I mean
okay for him can check and now Queen f5
would win now I didn't see that one fo
fo hangs okay this is not winning night
b7 is now winning her white attending
night d 8 double check this is the
decisive line and wide wins somehow okay
the computer jack and this was amazingly
still a draw if he finds night XP 7 Jack
which you didn't but ok it's it's
totally clear okay now king of 8 wins
this is just just a draw because of
rooks is seven ok nobody understands
that one yeah but here I'm winning
hopefully am yeah I am okay here Gucci
seven wins for white didn't see that one
okay I was winning on time but i didn't
i didn't look look that but that effort
anymore but rook g7 is winning this pawn
is promoting yeah this this is the
problem okay what a chaotic game but i
hope it was entertaining thanks for
watching